لا يملك الناس سوى الدعاء والامل لعل بعض
ذويهم ينهضوا من تحت الانقاض
ابو سيف الدين من سكان
المنكوبه بعد الزلزال
تعرف الرجل على مقتنيات اهله الذين فقدهم
انه يامل وحسب ان يصل رجال الانقاذ
لاخراجهم
مع زوجته وابنه في الحقل ثم وصلت عملي
وعادهما الى البيت الذي يبعد عشر دقائق عن
الحقل وتقديري انهما كان في المنزل عنده
وقوع الزلزال
كتبت الحياه لهذا الطفل ازكى مالك في ست
سنوات بعد بقائه تحت الانقاض لنحو 48 ساعه
بينما عثر على والدته وجدته متوفاهتين الى
جانبه في المنزل اما زكي فقد كان يتيم
الاب وبعد الزلزال صار يتيم الاب والام
بقي له جده ومشوار حياه
تقديم رعايه النفسيه لاطفال النازحين بعد
الصدمه والفقدان ومشاعر الخوف من الهزات
الارضيه
حصيله الدمار عشرات الاف منازل
لاصحاب البيوت المهدمه لن تكون كافيه مع
ذلك نشكر الرئيس على اهتمامه وندعو الله
اي يقوينا على مواجهه هذا الابتلاء
يتطلعوا عشرات الالاف المتضررين من
الزلزال الى ان تعينهم الحكومه والمنظمات
الانسانيه على اعاده اعمار منازلهم فبدون
ذلك العون سيكون من الصعب على ذوي الدخل
المحدود تشييد منازلهم سريعه وهما سيبقيهم
نازحين لفتره طويله صاحب جاسم الجزيره
محافظه اقليم الغربيه